[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous rejoindre sur
tv soixante dix huit pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 loisirs une édition un
peu particulière une édition spéciale
été nous allons vous donner tous les
conseils tous les bons plans pour
profiter du département des yvelines de
nombreuses idées et tout cela en
compagnie des journalistes de à la
rédaction grégory bonjour bonjour oui
oui notamment nous irons faire un tour
sur la scène tout à fait puisque la
scène c'est un théâtre un théâtre
d'inspiration c'est un axe fluvial
important soit aussi un théâtre
d'inspiration pour les peintres
impressionnistes et ça c'est au 19e
siècle avec vous nous agirons voir les
parcs de loisirs et les dernières
nouveautés
allez on ne cerne les parcs de loisirs
c'est une valeur sûre pour occuper les
enfants pendant l'été et ça même si le
temps est moche
et puis avec vous mélanie aussi là on
verra avec vous que la plage c'est aussi
en ville et oui pourquoi toujours au
bord de la mer pour avoir des grains de
sable entre les doigts de pied et on
fera le tour
et puis est bien évidemment un d'autres
rendez vous seront à suivre d'autres
rendez vous que nous vous détaillerons
au fur et à mesure de cette émission
nous irons aussi avoir des musées voir
les châteaux qui seront ouverts pendant
les vacances un programme très riche
deux invités est tout d'abord pour
débuter cette émission je me tourne vers
vous merci de nous recevoir tout d'abord
parce que nous sommes ici chez vous à
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines avec donc deux invités à
vincent couteau vous êtes responsable du
pôle événementiel et puis xavier quintin
vous êtes directeur des activités donc
de cette île de loisirs le mot d'ordre
pour cette saison c'est sport nature et
culture également et on va débuter avec
ce village sportif
jusqu'à quand est il proposé et qu'est
ce qu'on va pouvoir y trouverez alors le
viage sportifs et culturels
il est en place depuis
hier lundi jusqu'à vendredi de la
semaine prochaine donc là pendant deux
semaines
on y trouve presque 25 activités aussi
bien sportif donc de l' escalade du
rugby des activités peu connus comme du
tchoukball football alors ça joue avec
un trampoline
il faut jeter la base 100 entreprises
elle a rattrapé avant qu'elles touchent
le sol pour marquer des points
voilà mais aussi d'activités culturelles
avec un atelier découverte des métiers
de la radio
une exposition sur l'olympisme et une
exposition sur les trajectoires plutôt
sport plutôt culture pendant les
vacances et sport ça permet de bien tous
les excès de l'année puis la culture ça
fait du bien à l'esprit je suis pas pour
les autres
les autres pourront pas dire mieux
pareil et grégory sport oui vraiment
sport de sport pendant l'été c'est
important aussi on va faire un petit
tour du côté de ce village de sportifs
justement on se retrouve juste après à
ce reportage
look et sur gazon la nouveauté du
village sportif et culturel 2019 à lille
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
des sports des activités culturelles
proposées aux jeunes de 11 à 17 ans
certains ateliers sont animés par des
sportifs de haut niveau c'est le cas de
jérémy aicardi anciens joueurs de
l'équipe de france de rugby à 7
si aujourd'hui j'ai envie de transmettre
c'est parce que tout ce que j'ai appris
pendant ma carrière en tout cas
professionnels mais surtout avancer les
valeurs du rugby le portage les copains
plaisir que le coach tangle ou pas te
félicite quand tu fais des belles
actions avec des créneaux d'une heure
par ateliers les jeunes peuvent
découvrir des sports inhabituel escalade
ventriglisse et sandball ou encore une
activité d'équitation d'une durée d'une
heure trente du sport mais pas seulement
également on pourra retrouver de
l'initiation aux gestes qui sauvent bas
pour apprendre justement les gestes de
premiers secours et sur la partie
culturelle on va retrouver notamment un
atelier radio avec lfm radio une
exposition du cnoss donc sur une
exposition autour des jeux olympiques
illégalement est intégré l'exposition
trajectoire
une exposition sur la mobilité le
village sportif et culturel c'est du 8
au 19 juillet inscription obligatoire en
2018 près de 800 jeunes ont participé à
cet événement voilà pour ce village
sportif c'est l'une des nombreuses
activités qui seront proposées qui sera
proposée ici à lille le loisir à saint
quentin en yvelines avant de parler des
autres rendez vous ils vous attendez
beaucoup de monde cet été
en général ils de loisirs fait le plein
en respect on a extrêmement liés à la
météo
donc on a de la chance il fait beau il
fait pas trop chaud aujourd'hui parce
qu'on souffre effectivement également
des températures trop élevées
c'est aussi le risque est peut-être
aussi grand que le mauvais temps mais là
on a des conditions idéales et
apparemment ça se profile bien pour les
jours à venir
vous parliez des conditions météo
difficiles lorsqu'il fait trop chaud
mais on peut se rafraîchir depuis peu il
ya quelques saisons vous avez ouvert une
aire de jeu aussi tout à fait donc une
heure de jeu de haut pour les 0-12 ans
qui permet effectivement se rafraîchir
et qui seraient de plus en plus de
succès au fil des années la la
l'activité est bien rodé maintenant et
on a ouvert géré un peu plus tôt cette
année puisque des femmes est en fait
l'activité proposée
vous avez bien fait puisque les
températures fin mai était déjà bien
élevé pour pouvoir en profiter et puis
je précise tout de même que les parents
aussi peuvent se rafraîchir avec avec
les enfants le pousse à lire on parlait
de deux cultures aussi sur cette île de
loisirs de saint quentin le pousse à
lire ça va permettre de lire partout
dans la base
exactement c'est vraiment la deuxième
édition donc de 10 pouces à lire avec
l'opération de partir en livres et
l'idée c'est d'amener
ballet les familles les jeunes à la
lecture est donc là on a on a un
pousse-pousse qui a été mis aux couleurs
du pousse à lire qui va ce qui va
déambuler dans l'île des loisirs qui va
proposer aussi bien donc des livres
physiques mais aussi des livres audio
donc entre 20 et 40 minutes et donc les
jeunes pourront se poser et écouter
effectivement des livres qu'on était
quand même pris ce même pas encore sorti
en exclusivité qui sortiront à l'automne
quels sont les autres rendez vous
ponctuels comme ça que vous allez
organiser pour cette saison estivale
alors deux rendez vous importants le
ciné mobile donc un camion qui se
transforme en salle de cinéma 80 places
qui vient le 22 juillet avec trois
séances 14h30 17h30 et 20h30
et surtout le l'île de france fait le
théâtre avec la compagnie des tréteaux
de france qui est un superbe projet qui
mérite vraiment être reconnu donc c'est
assez fin août 24 août au 1er septembre
exactement sur la fin de la saison
exactement il ya aussi bien des ateliers
que des spectacles c'est fait par des
comédiens professionnels nous faut
vraiment profiter c'est gratuit donc
c'est vraiment un très très beau c'est
l'une des projets compagnie
qui bouge en france tout à fait deux
sites prévus et à la direction c'est
comme robin renucci qui est l'un des
plus grands comédiens ils étaient là
l'an dernier et c'est vraiment très bien
ce qu'ils font à découvrir à partir du
24 août jusqu'au 1er septembre à cette
compagnie les autres rendez vous il y en
a qui sont proposés régulièrement aussi
qu'ils ne sont pas bons qu elle pendant
sept pendant cet été
qu'est ce qu'on pourra faire sur cette
île de loisirs de saint quentin voilà
les activités traditionnelles mais qui
s'enrichissent d'activité plus récentes
je peux parler notamment du bng
injection qui peut la deuxième saison
est ouvert déjà depuis le mois de mars
dans la très loin d'ici on est du côté
on n'a pas situé sur l'île le loisir on
est du côté de on est tout près
lorsque nous sommes arrivés il y avait
voilà lorsque nous sommes arrivés il y
avait effectivement des personnes qui
s'apprêtait à décoller puisqu'on est à l
inverse du saut à l'élastique en fait on
part du soleil en injecter en hauteur
donc c'est une activité nouvelle qui est
gérée par le parcours acrobatique en
hauteur qui est juste à côté de nous ça
c'est pour grégorien je sais que nicolas
nicolas landry était également très
intéressé 1 quoi enfin leur art lui
envoie alors la route alors pourquoi pas
l'essayer pendant l'émission
pourquoi pas alors après pour les plus
jeunes
les gir même les très jeunes parce que
ça c'est une quelque chose d'important
conçoit développe et sur les loisirs les
activités pour les tout petits
donc le parc de jeu a été très renforcée
puisque les quasiment multiplié par 3
par l'allée passé avec je dirais des
nouvelles activités comme sony et
bulle d'eau etc donc il mérite d'être
découvert de re découvert parce qu'il
n'a rien à voir avec ce qui était
proposé l'année passée et puis également
dans ce même parc qui est un lieu géré
de balade pour les familles et pour les
tout petits des trottinettes électriques
des voitures pour les 2 ans voit même -
en fait télécommandé par les parents
donc on peut proposer des activités aux
tout petits qui se prennent pour des
grands noms dans ce parc et cela fait
très plaisir
voilà donc profiter de l'étang aussi
alors les activités qui sont proposées
avec les temps donc vous devez voir à
côté effectivement on reçoit du nouveau
matériel mais on a surtout de démarrer
une nouvelle activité notamment annuel
le paddle que l'on avait essayé déjà
ponctuellement l'année passée donc par
des cours j'irai à la séance
balas a remporté un certain succès donc
on essaie de proposer maintenant des
animations à l'année donc c'est toujours
en location et ça permet toujours de de
prendre le vent on va dire de se
rafraîchir par ces périodes ensoleillées
un programme très vaste merci à tous les
deux d'être venu nous en parler et de
dresser un petit peu le panorama de ce
qui est proposé ici à lille le loisir
une fois de plus on vous renvoie vers le
site internet il s'est affiché et vous
aurez toutes les dates parce qu'il y en
a beaucoup et un des évènements pour ne
rien manquer grégory ont parlé de
l'étang derrière vous vous êtes
carrément aller sur la scène faire une
photo à la une petite croisière qui est
proposé tout au long de l'été alors y en
a une quinzaine dans les yvelines par
l'office de tourisme de saint germain à
boucles de seine qui vous propose de
suivre la trace des peintres
impressionnistes
ils se sont inspirés de la scène dans
leur peinture au 19e siècle
11h en ce samedi ensoleillé du mois de
juillet 134 personnes sont venues
embarqué opecst pour cette croisière
pique nique sur la scène une bonne
dizaine d'années croisière sur la seine
c'est avec dès que le beau temps arrive
les gens se précipitent sur ces
croisières c'est un moment agréable sur
la seine à bord du thier vanot les
passagers présents pour la plupart en
famille partent sur les traces des
peintres impressionnistes
on connaît pas bien les îles qui sont
qui sont au milieu de la scène souvent
au passe devant sur la nationale 13 en
voiture mais on va jamais au plus proche
il ya développement également de la
navigation des cours aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de bâtiments et de lieux
qui ont été très fréquentés un deuxième
moitié du 19e siècle par surtout par des
ses auteurs des écrivains célèbres comme
mon passants ou essentiellement par des
peintres surtout puisque c'est ici dans
cet environnement qu'est née
l'impressionnisme notamment avec des
toiles qui ont été réalisés par monet et
renoir régions les plus célèbres les
ponts supérieurs et inférieurs du bateau
affiche complet pour la croisière un
voyage sur l'eau qui emmène les
participants le long des îles de la
scène de chatou à maisons laffitte
on était très curieux
et là on se rendre compte de tout les
différents endroits assez insolites
parfois donc c'est très sympa
après trois heures de quiétude à la
rencontre des peintres et auteur du 19e
siècle
l'heure est au débarquement est au bilan
ce sont des passagers plutôt relax et
que nous retrouvons super intéressant
vraiment un pin guide et elle nous a
appris plein de choses donc non vraiment
bien c'était très agréable
une balade assez surprenante la détente
en famille tout au long de l'été c'est
une quinzaine de croisière qui est
proposée sur la scène des traversées
calme et commentée comme celle
d'aujourd'hui ou d'autres plus festive
au son du jazz à suivre au cours de
cette édition spéciale du 7-8 loisirs
pour l'été une sélection de livres pour
vos vacances avec les libraires du pavé
du canal à montigny le bretonneux mais
également les trésors cachés à découvrir
dans les musées des yvelines avec un
reportage signé marylène ce sera avec
vous à tout à l'heure vous allez
auparavant nous parler d'un petit jeu
aussi qu'on peut pratiquer ensemble aux
hutus seul smic ecard ça s'appelle on va
parler dans un instant je pourrais je
précise juste que toute l'équipe nous a
rejoint pour cette cette séquence de
l'émission tous les journalistes que
vous voyez tout au long de l année sur
l'antenne marylène ce jeu met donc je
suis venu avec un sneak ecard donc c'est
un jeu qui a fait un carton aux états
unis il est édité en france par ces par
papa smicards du park-hôtel games qui
installe à versailles donc c'est un jeu
de cartes
mais un jeu de cartes qui est pas comme
les autres parce qu'ils jouent dans la
vie tous les jours et le principe c'est
que vous distribuez des cartes et sur
chacune d'entre elles se trouve un des
fils bienveillant à réaliser parce que
le bus c'est faire des choses
bienveillante et agréable pour tout le
monde donc une fois le défi effectué
vous remettez votre carte à quelqu'un et
elles peuvent se retrouver à faire le
tour du monde d'ailleurs il ya une
application qui a été créé avec 15 films
cartes font le tour du monde où ce sont
les participants qui font c'est la carte
fait le tour du monde avec les
participants s'est enrôlé en fait on se
remet dakar une fois qu'on l'a fait non
on peut suivre sa carte on peut suivre
sa carte sur chaque carte en fait vous
avez un petit numéro de suivi du truc et
sur l'application ces légendes on joue
le jeu et remplissent à chaque fois
qu'ils ont la carte on peut retrouver où
elle est donc ça peut durer
éternellement en fait cette histoire ce
qu'on peut lancer donc à partir de cet
été ce week end c'est fait par des parts
d par une maison d'édition versailles
yvelines aux quelques exemples de
mission peut-être là par exemple j'ai
payé un café à quelqu'un donc c'est là
où ça que je dis c'est toujours
bienveillant
qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir deux le sort
donc il ya différentes thématiques l'ag
et mangez végétarien pendant sept jours
barbecue inquiéter barbecue végétariens
ou appliquer une nouvelle recette nous
défend de faire des combos et faire
d'eux car quand même temps du coup mais
ce que je vous propose c'est qu'on va
jouer tous ensemble
donc je vous ai sélectionné des cartes à
chacun foyer c'est cette effervescence
qui s'empare du plateau
vous allez voir ça peut être très rigolo
où chacun a sa carte et vous avez
préparé des petites enveloppes en plus
on fait ça bien ici à tv 78 donc chacun
des fils à terre pendant l'émission faut
être discret il faut être discret donc
on rit on révèle ou pas nono digérer
l'arrivée c'est là dans ce cas là hop
bienveillant on m'a dit laisse faire le
tour à ces cas elle je vous laisse
passer j'imagine qu'il y en a une aussi
pour moi quelque part ça ce sera la
beauce est la mienne la salle du milieu
je crois pour vous gagnez up
manon et mélanie et on les montre pas
chacun de découvrir sa carte est comme
ça tout ton émission on va essayer de le
faire pour voir qui est le meilleur
agent secret de la bonne humeur un point
en pour enfants des missions qu'on a un
défi chacun à faire affaire au concept
émission ça
soyez pas surpris si cette émission
quelquefois a l'air un peu un peu
saugrenue on va dire ça comme ça c'est
juste le jeu de marylène donc tout au
long de cette émission on va essayer de
suivre ce jeu ce n'est qu'ils gardent ça
s'appelle vous pouvez donc le tester
chez vous et puis entre deux parties
peut être un petit peu de sorties aussi
avec vous ou mélanie mickey je vous
laisse passer le micro à mélanie et et
on va parler des différentes opérations
étaient en sable parce qu'elles se
multiplient paris avait un peu lancé la
mode ya quelques années maintenant c'est
partout dans les yvelines
et oui on peut aller à la plage en ville
dans les yvelines aussi on peut
connaître la sensation des grains de
sable entre les doigts de pied alors
pour cela il faut monter un peu plus au
nord du département ont paradis à
verneuil sur seine à la base de loisirs
du val de seine c'est une grande zone de
baignade qui est ouverte au public tous
les jours du 1er juillet au 1er
septembre et la baignade est surveillée
de 10h à 19h il ya donc de quoi être
rassuré il y a un droit d'entrée pour le
public à peu près 3 euros 90 pour un
enfant de moins de 14 ans et gratuit
pour les moins de 4 ans et 5 euros 50
points adultes alors sur cette île de
loisirs on peut faire plein de choses on
peut jouer au mini golf pêche à la carpe
faire du pédalo et plein d'autres
activités qu'on trouve sur le site
sur saint quentin en yvelines également
et oui là cette fois à montigny le
bretonneux
comme chaque année le parking du gymnase
alain colas se transforme en plage pour
faire des châteaux du toboggan c'est la
13ème édition cette année bt on sable
écoutez les participants on a trouvé que
c'était une très bonne idée de passer du
temps à l'été en sable et tous les ans
et la fidl le fait que ce soit voilà
aussi bien organisé c'est vrai qu'à pas
mal d'activités je regardais justement
le petit le petit programme donc c'est
vrai que c'est vraiment enfin c'est
plaisant voilà d'avoir autant
d'activités le savent déjà ce que
j'adore la mer donc c'est un avant goût
des vacances et ensuite l'ambiance c'est
plein d'animations donc l'ambiance est
agréable
des fois après tu fais la queue sur nuit
on m'a après des voyages vers un jeu
wayne watts était dans un grand toboggan
après la turquie après l'atteinte est
restée dans une piscine c'est avec la
boue c'est c'était trop bien
subtilité cette année pour montigny le
bretonneux l'opération est uniquement
réservé aux habitants de la commune mais
c'est un choix de la commune peuvent
s'est liée à la fréquentation des années
précédentes l'an dernier wilfried y
avait 33 mille visiteurs qui s'étaient
donné rendez vous tout l'été alors cette
année les unit montants peuvent en
profiter jusqu'au 18 août
et pour ceux qui voudraient piquer une
tête en restant à 50 ans on devine
pourquoi ne pas les attrape
depuis le 8 juillet c'est la dixième
édition de trappes l'âge un rendez-vous
qui l'an dernier avait recueilli 27
mille visiteurs au programme de cette
nouvelle édition le bassin de la piscine
jacquemond qu un solarium et de très
nombreuses animations comme des ateliers
du crossfit des concours de pétanque
l'accès est gratuit pour les trappistes
pour les non-résidents l'entrée est à 7
euros dispose adultes et 4 euros 40 pour
les enfants mais le billet donne accès
au site durant une semaine et vous
n'oubliez pas les uns les autres que
vous avez des défis à réaliser je vous
vois tous bien sage est ce que vous avez
tous pris connaissance de vos petites
cartes aussi ça vous semble faisable
c'est faisable c'est faisable c'est
faisable
oui marylène qui va arbitrer tout ça
grégory compliqué mais pas impossible on
va y arriver aurélie relèvera le des
très compliqué est ce qu'on va faire un
sans faute
michael moi y'a pas de souci là dessus
si ce sera relevée après le défi n'est
pas forcément réalisable uniquement sur
le plateau c'est oui c'est mieux que les
gens le voient quand même oui mais il va
falloir sortir le du plateau à un moment
donné en tout cas pour ma part d'accor
très bien
n'en dit pas plus mais c'est le suspense
la note de nicolas lhenry manon c'est
faisable
oui oui peut-être bientôt relever
bientôt relever la spéciale et mélanie
donc on est on y retourne à 7
cette chronique dédiée aux différentes
opérations étaient en sable cette fois
ci à plaisir est là c'est carrément
château en sable ouais c'est la vie de
château à plaisir si on peut le tenté
pendant des mois un mois et demi le parc
du château se transforme en parc
d'activités c'est la deuxième édition et
des jeux gonflables pour les enfants des
jeux d'eau du beach volley les vendredi
et samedi des animations éphémère il ya
des voiturettes électriques des murs
d'escaladé
c'est des moments à vivre dans les zones
fun et sport mais il ya aussi une zone
zen pour ceux qui voudraient boucler ou
tout simplement profiter du soleil
l'année dernière on a fait des plaintes
certaines journées à 600 enfants
accueillis avec les familles donc c'est
énorme donc cette année on a bien su
réitérer mais il n'était pas question de
faire un one shot
il fallait absolument que ça perdure
puisque c'est une vraie attend ce qui
fait que maintenant au niveau de l'été
on a toute une série d'activités entre
la nuit la nuit des étoiles mais aussi
la nuit des cinémas et puis ces
estivales les estivales ont débuté le 15
juillet le rendez-vous court jusqu'au 29
août aux moules frites dans tout ce que
j'ai donné ce que il ya un petit rendez
vous qui vous intéresse le programme est
trop vaste j'ai déjà oublié comment
attirer quelque chose que vous avez
annoncé
je vais voir cette émission un replay
c'était pas mon défi mais j'ai réussi à
caser vous pouvez consulter en replay
nicolas si je vous dis je te tiens tu me
tiens par la barbichette le premier de
nous deux qui rira quittera le plateau
ah bon perdu vous avez perdu et b côté
la place on va poursuivre cette émission
donc émission spéciale 7,8 loisirs
enregistré depuis l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines et nous
recevons la directrice du coup du pavé
du canal bonjour bonjour alors plateau
ça peut vous servir oui effectivement
j'ai fait était en totale improvisation
que la thématique avec vous on va
aborder les lectures de l'été c'est ça
voilà c'est ça alors non alignés avec
certains ouvrages qu'est-ce que les
yvelinois les saint quentinois peuvent
lire chez vous en tout cas alors il ya
un peu de bd des romans français et des
romans étrangers
vous présenter tout d'abord un roman
israéliens ont assez peu de littérature
israélienne traduite en français c'est
l'histoire de deux deux jeunes une jeune
femme qui est israélienne
un jeune homme qui est palestinien ils
se retrouvent à new york qu'ils y font
leurs études un soir ils se croisent ils
tombent follement amoureux et dans cette
parenthèse enchantée dans un new york un
peu qui fait un petit peu oui un peu
fantasmé on va dire il oublie totalement
le conflit israélo-palestinien ils
peuvent vivre entièrement leur amour
sans aucune contrainte
jusqu'au jour où leur visa expiré il va
falloir qu'ils adaptent leur histoire ou
au conflit et une belle histoire d'amour
approprié pour l'été oui tout à fait
c'est très beau alors donc il ya
d'autres romans aussi alors un roman
dont le titre est assez évocateur pour
cet été s'appelle stoner se meurt c'est
une jeune fille très belle issue d'une
famille plutôt aisée ça se passe au bord
du lac léman
un jour elle disparaît et c'est son
frère qui va nous raconter la
disparition de cette soeur et des
conséquences sur la vie de la famille
des secrets des trahisons et un frère
qui évidemment a beaucoup de mal à se
remettre de cette disparition
donc je vais un peu plus triste que le
roman oui le précédent n'est pas très
gai non plus mais voilà je me laisse les
lecteurs découvrir en amical qui va se
reconvertir au téléachat et de fait
vraiment très bien effectivement michael
mais ce n'est pas pour des films de
retour alors paulina mielleux votre
troisième roman michael va nous le
montrer c'est un roman américain oui
tout à fait un roman de grands espaces
l'histoire de deux soeurs après une
catastrophe qui mènent les états unis à
une panne d'électricité générale elles
vivent au fond de la forêt dans une
maison toutes les deux une et passionnée
de danse elle va danser jusqu'à jusqu'à
ce qu'elle n'est plus de piles dans son
transistor et mais elle va continuer à
écouter la musique qu'elle a dans la
tête et s'entraîner et la seconde soeur
elle était destinée à de grandes études
donc elle va
se cultiver le plus possible en lisant
tous les livres cas dans la maison et ça
va se terminer par la lecture des
encyclopédies qu'il y reste et on va
suivre leur destin évidemment elles vont
rencontrer des gens ça va plus ou moins
bien se passer
c'est un beau portrait de femme et un
beau un beau roman sur la faible un peu
poétique aussi avec oui alors deux
autres romans et après je vais vous
demander vos avis vos romans préférés
parmi la présentation que nous a fait
paulina miettes alors le quatrième roman
est un roman français n'est d'aucune
femme de franck bouyer
c'est un roman plus récent qui a reçu le
prix des libraires
c'est encore un beau portrait de femme
suit le destin de rose
en fait on découvre ses carnets au début
du roman cette jeune femme a été vendu
en tout cas employé par un noble
elle est issue d'une famille de paysans
qui avait plus de moyens pour subvenir à
leurs besoins donc elle est employée
pour être bonne à tout faire assez vite
son rôle
ces temps on va dire voilà on suit son
histoire à travers ses carnets n'est
d'aucune femmes c'est ça implique la
naissance d'un enfant dont on suit aussi
le destin de cet enfant c'est un très
beau roman c'est une personnalité très
forte une femme assez impressionnante
d'accord donc là aussi encore quelque
chose
focalisé sur une personne plutôt que
huit rayons tout à fait remis et le
dernier alors le dernier c'est une bd
pour changer un petit peu ce qu'on peut
aussi lire des bd sur la plage donc
mezine grace
c'est une bd française qui a un format
un peu comme x c'est un premier tome on
est en 2035 huit ans après une
catastrophe nucléaire aux états unis les
etats unis sont réduits à une bande qui
s'étend de new york à la californie et
sur ce territoire
chacun essaye de survivre et on suit le
destin d'un an père et de sa fille qui
s'appelle joyce qui est une enfant de
l'hiver nucléaire
elle a des quelques particularités c'est
pas une enfant normale et voilà il faut
qu'il arrive à préserver sa fille tout
en essayant d'avoir une fille à peu près
normale
or là on s'éloigne un peu de du coup de
lime on n'est plus dans l'imaginaire on
s'éloigne de la réalité c'est plus de la
fiction
oui oui voilà c'est un peu plus
fantastique oui alors est-ce que vous
avez une préférence parmi les livres que
donc nous vous pouvez retrouver vos
téléspectateurs aux pavés du canal
marylène or moi vous aimez vous savez
j'aime bien quand on parle des femmes
n'est donc qu'une femme samedi bien
banon sous la même étoile me tente bien
un peu de romantisme de revendre été
pour cet été 2010 9 aurélie mois se met
rien que pour le titre pour le l'été à
fond dans les théories mélanie moi j'ai
cru entendre parler de danse donc mon
coeur va aller vers la danse nicolas
gaitan compris le roman américain et
pour vous michael ce que j'ai dans la
main justement amazing grace salaire
très science fiction mikaël joannides
rhône pour la plage c'était je pense
merci michael alors marylène je me
tourne vers vous parce que on va aller
faire un petit tour au musée et me
nicolas je sais pas si vous saviez il ya
trop de fuites musée dans les yvelines
des musées et des maisons d'hommes
célèbres comme on dit et moi je suis
allé en voir quatre d'entre eux pour
dénicher quatre pièces originales à
bouger à projets dont refusé d une ligne
des pièces d'extraordinaire
dehors de votre histoire à chacune
faisait sa pépite
direction le renvoyer
parmi les 4000 références de ce musée
dédié au petit train une micheline sa
particularité se trouve dans ses roues
en pneus michelin
le chef d'entreprise a souhaité
fabriquer ce pneu rails pour le confort
des voyageurs
et si ce train jouir présente un
prototype son modèle final à quelques
très différents la micheline en 1931
relie paris deauville en 2h03 ça paraît
un peu comme ça très précis et très
cadré mais en fait elle bat de 32
minutes le record de la vapeur
d'ailleurs il ya les journaux en ont
parlé
c'est un peu le la course entre david et
goliath donc d'avis de la micheline
goliath le gros la grosse mastodontes de
la vapeur mesdames et messieurs restons
dans le jouer partout à poissy après
trois ans de fermeture pour rénovation
le musée du jouet a rouvert ses portes
en mai dernier
il retrace l'histoire de ses compagnons
de notre enfance en commençant dès
l'antiquité
grâce à un dépôt du musée du louvre nous
avons déjà là des poupées
nous avons une toupie des osselets nous
avons des hochets pour les tout petits
et puis même un jouet avec des petites
rule qui était attirée le tout étant
introduit par un panneau de sarcophage
sans doute d'une sépulture d'enfants
donc c'est un dépôt d'objets magnifiques
d'une grande ancienneté et nous sommes
particulièrement fiers et touché par la
confiance du musée du louvre et indiana
jones les trésors d
pensez à faire un tour du côté du
château de dampierre le domaine dont le
parc a rouvert au printemps sort de ces
hangars les calèches de la famille de
luynes pour une première présentation
avant la création d'un musée dédié
parmi ce parc hippomobile une calèche de
gala cette calèche a été l'occasion lors
du mariage famille d'uzès avec la
famille de luynes d'un grand mariage la
famille d'uzès évidemment avec la
duchesse d'uzès qui est très connu dans
les yvelines et donc pour ce mariage sa
fille avec un duc de luynes est bien
parti sur paris pour remonter les champs
elysées passe par la cour d
de belize est justement du palais
présidentiel pour présenter au président
la république
nous avons aussi ici la marque de
carrossier donc morel à paris et
celui-là c'est le numéro 15 162 quittons
la route et les chevaux pour les fleurs
beau musée de la batellerie de conflans
sainte honorine
le conservateur sort de sa vitrine des
objets rares fraîchement confié au musée
par les descendants de son auteur
j'adore ce petit avion ils sont l'oeuvre
de jean jourdain rentrée en centres
d'apprentissage dans une usine de
chaudronnerie à l'âge de 12 ans dans le
cadre des ses études il fabrique ce
globe et cet avion avant de passer héros
scaphandre quand il a dû trouver du
travail
il a décidé de créer une société pour
fabriquer du matériel pour ce calendrier
et il a fabriqué des casques réel donc
on en a ici un modèle de sa main
également donc imaginé et fabriqué tout
ça avec des systèmes de martelage et
pourquoi est-ce qu'il s'est lancé dans
cette production
parce que au lendemain de la seconde
guerre mondiale avec toutes les
destructions tous les bateaux coulés
dans les ports fluviaux toutes les mines
qui avaient été laissées par les
allemands il y avait énormément de
travail il a fallu recruter former
énormément de calendrier ce modèle
intacte n'a pas servi un scaphandrier il
est la dernière création de l'artisan
avant de donner les clés de son atelier
un souvenir qui l'a accompagné dans son
salon jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
merci à pauline amiens de la librairie
du pavé du canal pour cette sélection de
livres et vous le voyez j'ai retrouvé ma
place nicolas landry est parti à ce
qu'il s'est bien débrouillé pendant que
j'étais pas là voilà bonne provision
bien michael je vous rend votre carte
marylène j'ai relevé mon défi si je te
tiens tu me tiens par la barbichette et
joséphine coleman berger qui nous
rejoint et qui doit se demander ce qui
arrive
nous avons quitté notre plateau bonjour
ça nous a dit je loisirs à saint quentin
en yvelines
on est plutôt pas mal on est plutôt
moyen d'installer oui c'est le cahier on
va parler des activités proposées par le
département parce que vous êtes maire de
plaisir vice-présidente de 50 ans et
puis aussi vice présidente du conseil
départemental des yvelines
parlons déjà plus globalement de la
politique du tourisme à 50 dans les
yvelines pardon en général l'été période
importante et le département accompagne
ce tourisme alors que ce soit pour les
étrangers qui viennent des autres
départements que pour les yvelinois les
yvelines aux associés oui bien sûr
aujourd'hui vous savez on a fait un
regroupement de développement
touristique avec le 92 comme vous le
savez et cette mission tourisme est
quelque chose de fondamental puisque on
s'est non seulement rendu compte parce
qu'on le savait depuis longtemps quand
même que ce département est un
département de grandes richesses
touristiques et de développement
économique ce qui n'est pas rien alors
comme vous le rappeliez et vous avez
raison de dire on n'est pas simplement
un appel de tourisme une départementale
mais également d'ile-de-france et voire
internationale je vous ferai pas
l'affront de vous rappeler les grands
châteaux que nous avons sur notre départ
il n'y a pas que versailles ans c'est ça
qu'il faut faire découvrir aussi y'a pas
de versailles
on a énormément de château à visiter
mais on a pas que ça parce que je
voudrais vous dire en préambule c'est
avant toute chose avant de venir essayer
de prendre la carte pass malin parce que
c'est ça qui est important avant que je
vous décrive tout ce qui va se passer
dans le départ ce qui importe c'est une
carte gratuite pour 5 personnes
c'est-à-dire une famille pratiquement et
qui vous donne la possibilité d'avoir
une réduction de 15 % sur toutes les
activités illinois c'est à dire les
monuments mais aussi ça vous savez que
nous avons des onze nous avons également
des endroits pour faire je dirais des
visites patrimoniales historique donc
tout ça passe mal un avant tout c'est ce
que je vous disponible notamment dans
les offices de tourisme voilà tout à
fait est si fondamental de le dire
on a des grandes manifestations alors
c'est vrai vous avez raison
l'été n'est pas un moment où le
département doit abandonner les
yvelinois c'est un département qui se
dit que l'été il ya beaucoup de gens qui
partent certes mais pas de moi ils
partent une semaine quinze jours donc il
faut trouver des activités
donc c'est ce que l'on fait on a des
grandes manifestations qui vont avoir
lieu sur le département des
manifestations vous avez dû certainement
en parler avant même que je vous en
parle mais dd nous savait que sur
département le cyclisme est quelque
chose de fondamental est que nous allons
avoir à rambouillet la dernière étape du
tour de france c'est quand même pas rien
on vous dirait sepa et divine qu'il des
quileute si si c'est quand même une
divine qui s'en occupent l'angleterre
venir des touristes pour découvrir le
reste du département
exactement et puis on a aussi une grande
manifestation au niveau du mois d'août
début août comme l'equirando avec un
rassemblement de mille cavaliers ce qui
n'est pas rien et 800 chevaux
tout ça au bréviaire c'est un espace qui
est vraiment dédié
je dirais à cette activité mais qui est
départementale il y a également vous
savez des grandes balades qui sont
organisées au niveau de tout ce qui est
vélo parce que nous avons le fameux
paris brest alors c'est pas du gâteau
mais jour presque tellement c'est un
plaisir de se balader en vélo sur ces
pistes cyclables que nous aménageons
puisque le département des yvelines est
un département cyclable qui est très
important on a aussi les nuits du cinéma
c'est pas rien ensuite à cannes il faut
bien être dans cette continuité en a
dans divers lieux du département
et bien cette manifestation qui
fonctionne très très bien le département
accompagne financièrement au niveau de
la com et accompagne également au niveau
de l'aménagement avec des chaises
saleh pour presque dormir si le film ne
vous intéresse pas on fait ça c'est
vraiment toi et puis bien sûr on a tous
les réseaux de visite des châteaux puis
des maisons des illustres puisque vous
savez que les impressionnistes c'est
quand même quelque chose de très
important sur les départements on a une
également une grande manifestation qui
va avoir lieu à la fin de l'été début
septembre dans le parc du peuple de
l'herbe
vous savez que ce parc a été
complètement aménagé par le département
113 hectares 18 millions d'euros
d'investissements sur ce parc avec toute
une série d'activités tourner vers les
familles particulièrement
mais début septembre c'est
une grande grande manifestation qui va
avoir lieu c'est la première fois et on
espère attirer plusieurs milliers de
personnes pour découvrir ce parc qui est
un parc bien sûr qu'ils aient
départementale complètement
départementale et puis j'en passe et des
meilleurs vous avez des manifestations à
toit rigide dans le parc de thoiry qui
était un lieu magique qu'il faut
absolument découvrir
je crois qu'aujourd'hui ça attire des
gens de la france entière
c'est ça qui est bien si vous aviez un
coup de coeur dans le département un
rendez vous incontournable de l'été
quelque chose à découvrir peut-être de
méconnu aussi j'aurais tendance à dire
le parc du peuple de l'herbe quand même
parce que si vous voulez c'est ainsi un
bras de la seine vous savez que la scène
aussi est un enjeu départementale
puisque aujourd'hui nous voulons
vraiment développer l'axé seine nous
travaillons d'ailleurs avec les cinq
départements qui vont de paris jusqu'au
havre de façon à créer des activités
tout le long de cette scène puisque
durant de nombreuses années les villes
tourner le dos à la scène alors
qu'aujourd'hui on veut réintégrer et se
réapproprier la scène donc je dirais le
parc du peuple de l'herbe
parce qu'il ya des choses à voir à
visiter y ait de la faune et de la flore
et on a surtout reconstitué je dirais un
environnement qui est un environnement
yvelinois avec une une attirance je
dirais de développement durable de
biodiversité
et puis également d'activités pour pour
tous les âges
donc c'est peut-être mon coup de coeur
de la nuit et concernant la scène vous
parliez tout à l'heure des
impressionnistes on sait que c'est un
lieu d'histoire aussi pour ses
impressionniste on l'a vu un reportage
tout à l'heure bien sûr c'est un lieu
d'histoire et puis si vous le permettez
j'aimerais bien vous dire deux mots de
bougival et du grand projet de bougival
parce que comme vous le savez il ya un
grand projet qui est en train de naître
autour autour de la maison de bizet
puisque le département a fait
l'acquisition de la maison de bizet ce
n'est pas rien mais également autour de
la datcha de tourguéniev est également
de la villa viardot qui a été accompagné
par monsieur berne comme vous le savez
faire par monsieur berne mais nous par
l'intermédiaire de monsieur des mois le
président de la république est venu sur
place pour voir ce projet puisque là il
doit ya voir la naissance d'un centre
européen musical qui aujourd'hui est
accompagnée
véritablement par le gouvernement et par
l'europe donc là ou si vous lisiez il ya
des impressionnistes qui sont à
proximité
et on a aussi ses maisons des illustres
que nous essayons aujourd'hui de faire
vivre et de faire naître il ya une carte
qui est sorti justement dans les
yvelines avec un descriptif très précis
de tous ces endroits à découvrir qu'ils
sont des endroits comme vous le disiez
historique patrimoniaux et également de
loisirs on a sur la scène des endroits
magnifiques de loisirs si vous aimez
l'eau il faut il faut y aller parce
qu'il ya des activités sportives qui
sont vraiment à développer et puis de
l'accrobranche enfin c'est un
département qui vaut la peine
le département très riche la carte vous
la retrouverez dans les offices de
tourisme notamment et c'est là aussi où
vous trouverez ce fameux passe mal an
dont nous parlions tout à l'heure pour
avoir des réductions assure toutes les
activités qui sont proposées dans le
département merci beaucoup je ne suis
comme anne verger vous parliez tout à
l'heure des différents châteaux et est
justement michael vous avez fait la
route des châteaux justement dans le
département exactement mais juste avant
je vais faire mon petit défi wilfrid ces
provinces elfi avec une personne voilà
manager voilà ça sera avec vous on leur
faire aussi avec la vie est quand même
assez berger je soupçonne de la triche
dans les attributions des cartes s'était
pas déjugé avoir une fille si l'un pour
mickaël de faire des scènes fille
monsieur selphy c'est son surnom à la
rédaction
merci encore joséphine coleman verger
michael cette route des châteaux
effectivement alors j'ai pu visiter
trois lieux emblématiques des yvelines
regardez la séquence j'ai pris mon sac à
dos et j'y suis allé
[Musique]
je vous propose de vous emmener sur la
route des châteaux des yvelines il y en
a une vingtaine dans le département et
nous en avons sélectionné trois à ces
partis
première escale le château de
monte-cristo port-marly cet ancien
vignoble a été transformée par
l'écrivain alexandre dumas à la moitié
du 19e siècle
présentation de ce style néo renaissance
[Musique]
on
à mots pour caractériser ce château ils
portent toute l'âme d'alexandre dumas
je crois que c'est ça qui caractérise
monte cristo essentiellement et qu'est
ce qui fait sa spécificité selon elle le
château est sculpté de toutes parts vous
pourrez voir des visages d'écrivains des
sculptures diverses des instruments de
musique des armes d
des personnages mi ange mi végétaux des
bouquets de fleurs des bouquets de
fruits face et c'est très étonnant
il faut lire la façade du château
aujourd'hui il fait très beau on peut se
promener dans les jardins c'est aussi ça
qui fait la beauté du lieu
oui bien sûr le château est inscrit dans
un parc romantique aménagé à l'anglais
avec des grottes des rocailles des
cascades c'est vraiment un vrai bonheur
de se promener là et vous organiser des
événements également pendant cet été
cet été nous avons une exposition d'art
contemporain qui est installée au
deuxième étage du château il faut venir
voir des oeuvres très étonnante d'un
artiste américain qui s'appelle à doute
jamal merci beaucoup frédéric il
résister tout ça
quand
deuxième étape de notre périple après le
style néo renaissance place au style
médiéval
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
loi des ruines mais est ce qu'il est
vraiment horrible alors effectivement
lorsqu'on s'approche de ce château on a
vraiment l'impression d'un tas de ruine
envahie par la végétation
il faut quand même que vous sachiez que
ce château déjà en plus de mille ans
d'histoire il fut forteresse médiévale
il a été ensuite résidence royale est
aujourd'hui effectivement il nous donne
cette image un petit peu délabré bien
sûr il y à toute l'histoire est passée
par céline mais il est toujours vivant
il est toujours debout et son histoire
est particulièrement intéressante il un
avantage également c'est qu'il est
gratuit si on veut venir pour visiter
autour on peut le voir tout à fait nous
sommes l'association qui nous occupons
particulièrement du château nous
assurons des visites pour des groupes
constitués ou pour des rendez-vous mais
surtout pour les journées du patrimoine
le dimanche des journées du patrimoine
il sera ouvert à tous le public de 10h à
18h le soir gratuitement
et là nous faisons des visites racontant
l'histoire de ce grand château
[Musique]
troisième étape de notre périple le
donjon de houdan qui datent du 12e
siècle on va le visiter
[Musique]
oh
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut visiter ici
dans le donjon de houdan alors on peut
visiter une exposition toute l'année sur
le donjon de goût dans sur son histoire
sur ces différentes occupations et
utilisation au cours des siècles mais on
peut aussi visiter des expositions
temporaires en ce moment une exposition
sur les chouettes jusqu'à la fin août
c'est aussi l'occasion de découvrir le
patrimoine des yvelines oui le donjon de
houdan c'est un monument historique de
la fin du xiième siècle
il a été rénové récemment et il est
ouvert au public depuis trois ans
maintenant et combien ça coûte ça coûte
4 euros pour les adultes 2 euros pour
les enfants jusqu'à 6 ans et c'est
gratuit pour les enfants de moins de 6
ans
à
avec ces trois visites j'espère que je
vous ai donné envie de découvrir le
patrimoine yvelinois si vous avez encore
des questions rendez vous sur le site
internet divine tourisme moi je vais
continuer encore un petit peu les
visites
[Musique]
et si les châteaux sont nombreux dans le
département les parcs d'attractions tout
autant relie les uns indices pour
découvrir un premier lieu si je vous dis
maquette à bravo michael moi je n'avais
pas de micro perdu france miniature
miniature très bien michael bravo le
seul endroit évidemment dont kyle en
cours où vous pouvez faire le tour de
france en quelques heures on rappelle 1
117 monuments sont reproduits il ya
également quelques manèges et pour cet
été eh bien le parc vous invite au
cirque des zinzins sous un chapiteau un
circuit avec des petites voitures et
puis à 4 mètres au dessus du sol il ne
faut pas avoir le vertige vent ateliers
permettent de tester votre équilibre
quelques explications supplémentaires
avec le directeur de france miniature la
thématique du cirque parce que c'est
vraiment pour consensuelle en fait c'est
très familial
et ça plaît énormément aux enfants donc
les plans voulais que ça soit aussi les
jeux d'aventuré le défi et ne cire que
s'y prête par les jeux d'ateliers et des
cnim alors le cirque des zinzins bien
sûr est compris dans le prix du billet
je me rappelle 22 euros pour les adultes
16 euros pour les enfants j'ai quand
même un bon plan qui va faire du bien
votre portefeuille puisque si vous
prenez vos billets en ligne sur le site
france miniature point fr moins cher
voilà pour les familles du coup
exactement parce qu'on dépense pendant
les vacances
juste un mot sur le cirque des onze ans
est accessible aux enfants à partir de 1
mètre et pour participer il faut
impérativement avoir des chaussures
fermées à partir d'un mètre a priori ici
tout le monde veut participer même mois
autre part qu'à proposer des nouveautés
pour cet été au parc de thoiry
oui et l'expérience proposée s'appelle
wild forest qui veut dire en anglais
forêt faune sauvage sauvage sur travaux
freinage et fouillé dans mon association
alors cela permet tout simplement d'être
en immersion avec certains animaux alors
cela existait en déjà puisqu'on pouvait
être en immersion avec des kangourous ou
encore avec des lémuriens
mais depuis quelques semaines et bien
vous pouvez côtoyer de très mignon d'un
ou encore plus insolite des vautours
c'est moins mignon oui c'est moins
mignon
alors c'est vrai que ces oiseaux en fait
on en très mauvaise presse en mais
rassurez vous il n'y a aucun danger
puisque vous êtes dans une volière de
500 mètres carrés qui est fermée donc
dans laquelle plusieurs rapaces évolué
vous pouvez laisser vos enfants pendant
que vous visitez le pas apparemment rien
appris
il n'y a pas de danger alors que grégory
et déjà habillé pour se fondre dans le
décor
merci michael mais vous êtes un peu sur
le même thème également également alors
que certaines espèces en fait de
vautours sont en voie d'extinction et du
coup c'est cette zone d'immersion en
fait un rôle pédagogique comme nous
l'expliquent mathieu décombe c'est le
responsable adjoint du service aventure
à thoiry on voit que à l'intérieur de
ces zones d'immersion les gens sont
beaucoup plus concentrés beaucoup plus
détendue et puis vont être plus à
l'écouté pour apprendre plein de choses
sur les animaux puisque c'est un nos
principaux rôles les moisséens c'est mon
travail ici à thoiry ça va être
d'expliquer plein de choses sur les
animaux aux visiteurs les sensibiliser à
leur protection et dans ces zones
d'immersion on arrive encore mieux à le
faire durant l'été il devrait faire beau
ça a plutôt bien commencé mais si jamais
quelques gouttes de pluie s'invite
il ya une solution et les parcs de jeux
intérieure ce sont des structures qui
sont réservées généralement aux enfants
de 1 à 12 ans alors ils peuvent bien sûr
un se défouler sur des châteaux
gonflables des trampolines des toboggans
des piscines à balles
il en existe plusieurs dans les yvelines
et justement il ya seulement quelques
mois un nouvel établissement ouvert ses
portes du côté de gaz rend si juste à
côté de rambouillet
son nom les mini kids j'ai fait une
étude de marché j'ai vu que dans le
secteur y avait rien pour les enfants et
donc j'ai trouvé que c'était très
intéressant d'ouvrir un lieu dédié aux
enfants sur embrouillé
c'est quand même des structures très
grande pour les personnes qui habitent
parfois en appartement on n'a pas ce
genre de superficie et des jeux de cette
taille pour pouvoir occuper ses enfants
pendant plusieurs heures et le petit
plus dans ce parc est bien il ya un
snacking donc du coup les parents
peuvent se détendre en buvant un café en
feuilletant un magazine et puis
évidemment tout en surveillant leurs
enfants infos pratiques ces 7 euros pour
les enfants de moins de 3 ans 10 euros
pour les enfants à partir de 3 ans et
c'est gratuit pour les adultes plus
d'infos sur le site qui s'affiche en bas
de l'écran
merci aurelia un parc d'attractions qui
vous attire plus qu'un autre dans le
département ou parcs d'attraction ou non
je pense à thoiry aussi mais moi j'ai
testé les cinq des onze ans c'est pas
mal en cire que des ans un bonbon
expérience michael je suis plus touahri
j'adore toi et l'adorer touahri pour les
animaux pour les voir les animaux pour
les rapaces elle que je vais essayer de
me fondre dans le décor également
avec grégory peut-être cet été et
franchement nature pour les france
minimes
chacun pourra y trouver à grégory va
tout prix partagé avec nous son
expérience des parcs pour partager avec
vous ce que j'étais un peu frustré tout
à l'heure sur la chronique de nicolas ce
qui est très important aurélie vous le
savez vous qui présentait des émissions
c'est bien s'hydrater entre les plateaux
en plus il fait chaud
donc je vais vous offrir ce petit verdot
voilà pour vous reposer après cette
longue chronique
c'est très mignon et ça permet de
relever un nouveau défi
le fil rouge depuis le début de cette
émission restent dans la thématique des
parcs de loisirs et un parc que vous
n'avez pas cité
et c'est la fête des loges trois cent
soixante sept ans qu'elle se déroule
dans un forêt a de saint-germain-en-laye
c'est jusqu'au 18 août l'événement
forain est le plus ancien de france mais
il ya toujours des nouveautés reportage
c'est sa première alors qu'il goûte à
tous les manèges sera pas cette année ce
sera l'année prochaine
que ce soit pour une balade en famille
ou des sensations fortes entre amis la
fête des loges à plein de ressources
pour cette 367e les visiteurs peuvent
découvrir plus de 200 animations stands
jeux
et bien sûr les traditionnels manèges je
pense que c'est merveilleux
c'était génial vraiment génial et bien
c'est quoi c'est plus convivial que la
foire du trône qui est très grande a
fait un peu plus convivial et on respire
c'est mieux si certains sont venus pour
un moment de détente d'autres ont bien
sûr profité de la visite en forêt de
saint germain en laye pour monter dans
les attractions les plus
impressionnantes et le courage n'est pas
à bloc chez tout le monde
je sais pas j'aime pas les sensations
fortes j'ai peur des salles et
courageuse que nous entendons ça
justement des sensations fortes mais on
aime ça donc on choisit les manèges les
plus attentionnés
c'est la première et la seule à temps
ouais non là c'est bon ça nous a
retourné un petit peu le coeur mais
sympa vous avez jusqu'au 18 août pour
profiter de la fête des loges plus de
deux millions de visiteurs sont attendus
sur place s'étaient dit
le 7-8 loisirs qui se poursuit à présent
avec une nouvelle a invité en plateau ou
virginie le vote
bonjour bonjour merci de nous rejoindre
ici donc à lille de loisirs pas très
loin du pnr bnr dont vous êtes la
chargée de communication le parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
on est aux portes de ce pnr ici un
parent qui compte cinquante et une
commune la majorité sont dans les
yvelines et puis on a une partie une
petite partie aussi en essonne l'été en
termes de tourisme moment
particulièrement important pour le pmr
oui c'est un moment qui rassemble aussi
des gens venus un peu de tous horizons
des franciliens qui restent sur place et
qui ont envie un peu de s'oxygéner des
gens d'un peu plus loin de france et
d'autres pays
et c'est vrai qu'on a un territoire un
peu exceptionnelle qui marie des îlots
de nature extraordinaire du patrimoine
des sentiers aménagés des sites à
visiter
donc il ya une offre naturellement très
riche ayant plus un certain nombre
d'acteurs touristiques qui propose tout
au long de l'année et particulièrement
l'été des sorties aménager des visites
organisées des ateliers un peu insolite
voilà des choses qui permettent de
découvrir autrement le patrimoine et
donc du coup d'en profiter
voilà sous le soleil ça le soleil on va
essayer de dresser un petit peu le
catalogue de ses différentes activités
nature patrimoine paysage terroir tous
ces aspects là sont mis en avant et puis
ça s'adresse et là je voudrais souligner
dès maintenant aussi aux plus jeunes il
ya des chantiers pour les jeunes pendant
l'été qui sont organisées au sein du pn
oui c'est une particularité aussi on
essaye de faire en sorte que des jeunes
est l'occasion de découvrir ce
patrimoine mais aussi en étant acteur et
donc il ya un certain nombre de
chantiers qui sont proposés ça peut être
des chantiers sur des sites naturels ou
pour lequel il ya des aménagements des
défrichements des mises en valeur de
sites anciens de vestiges sur lequel
voilà il ya des interventions pas trop
techniques qui sont à la portée de
personnes voilà non spécialistes qui
vont se réunir le temps d'un chantier
qui vont à la fois croisé d'autres
nationalités parce que tous les
chantiers qu'on a mené depuis plusieurs
années ça réunit des coréens d'aider des
philippins des
et des gens d'amérique du sud voilà
c'est vraiment un brassage déjà culturel
qui est passionnant c'est la découverte
d'un site et puis aussi de d'un rapport
au patrimoine comment l'entretien pour
qu'on entretient qu'est ce que c'est que
le travail de mémoire et en quoi c'est
important de garder ces vestiges et puis
après ils vivent ensemble et ensuite ils
découvrent ensemble directement aussi
puisqu'il ya une partie travaille le
matin une partie détente loisirs et
visite l'après midi donc c'est à la fois
voilà quelque chose d'utile quelque
chose de très agréable et c'est ouvert
évidemment à des internationaux puisque
c'est organisé avec l'association
rempart ile-de-france est évidemment
aussi ouvert à des locaux qui voudraient
profiter de l'occasion pour découvrir
donc c'est vraiment des rencontres
particulières il y en a au mois de
juillet qui sont déjà bouclées il y en a
au mois d'août qui sont encore ouverts
on peut aussi penser à nancy pour le
mois d'août
voilà donc il ya tous les renseignements
sur le site du parc et c'est vraiment
une expérience particulière pour joindre
l'utile à l'agréable
alors qui dit parc naturel dit aussi
forcément balade des balades pour tout
découvrir autour de différents thèmes et
les balades pour les petits curieux on
reste sur les enfants oui alors on a la
chance d'avoir des guides de parcs
extrêmement compétents qui connaissent
aussi bien la nature le patrimoine
l'histoire voilà tout ce qui est
intéressant et qui savent le transmettre
aux jeunes publics et donc ils proposent
ces rendez vous réguliers qui sont pour
des enfants de 6 à 12 ans où on va aussi
bien apprendre à calculer
là comment on calcule la hauteur d'un
arbre comme on apprend à se repérer en
forêt comme on décèle les traces de
présence animale dans un site comme on
fait une lecture de paysage par voilà
toutes ces choses là qui permettent de
faire une balade dans des paysages
évidemment très beau puisque c'est aussi
bien au milieu du marais demain cours
que de la forêt des hauts baignères
enfin voilà des sites un peu magique
quand on se dit qu'on est à 30 minutes
de paris c'est vrai que on débarque dans
ces endroits là et on se dit waow faire
voilà est donc en même temps on apprend
des choses on s'amuse
enfin voilà puis c'est vraiment des
guides passionnant donc on à solène qui
fait des visites avec une thématique de
diversité un petit peu plus forte on à
aurélie ehrlich qui est guide
conférencière avec une forte connotation
médiévale et qui donc du coup propose
dans le cadre du château de la madeleine
des ateliers autour du moyen-âge aussi
bien la mode vestimentaire au moyen-âge
comment s'habiller
pourquoi les codes vestimentaires et
puis les enfants apprennent aussi à
réaliser des accessoires voilà c'est
vraiment très pratique les blasons leur
signification comment on fabrique un
blason enfin voilà des choses qui
permettent de s'ouvrir un petit peu à
des choses moins connu et tout en ayant
voilà un cadre privilégié pour le faire
donc c'est vraiment des ateliers qui
marche très bien et qui sont vraiment
plébiscité par les enfants qui le font
les uns et les autres vous connaissez ce
pnr un petit peu vous avez l'habitude de
vous y rendre de découvrir des choses
le château de la madeleine oui on y on
le fréquente notamment pour des
reportages mais c'est très agréable
aussi d'aller s'y promener à la hauteur
en haut de ce village de saint rémy les
chevreuse et de chevreuse aussi juste
juste à côté c'est que c'est très
agréable
il ya pas mal de promenade ishare qu'on
parle peut-être de ces randonnées ses
ballades justement et en a quelques-unes
ya même une application qui était lancée
oui alors l'application rendent au pnr
ile de france elle les communes en fait
aux quatre parcs et de l'île de france
puisqu'en fait la vallée de chevreuse et
l'un des ses quatre parcs naturels
régionaux
il ya le vexin et le gâtinais ya oise
pays de france et ensemble ces quatre
parcs sont dit qu'ils avaient une offre
valade randonnée qui était vraiment
intéressante pour l'ensemble des
franciliens et que le faire ensemble
c'était plus rusé pour la mettre à
disposition beaucoup plus de circuits
donc il ya une centaine de balades et de
circuits référence et ça fait à peu près
1000 km de sentiers balisés qui sont
aussi bien que ses cibles à cheval à
vélo avait été à pied faire donc voilà
on peut choisir selon la durée le type
de paysage qu'on a envie de visiter le
parc qui est le plus proche de chez soi
et donc c'est vrai que ça permet voilà
d'avoir le circuit sur une appli avec en
plus des systèmes de téléchargement qui
font que le la cartographie et
téléchargé à l'avancé donc du coup même
quand on ne capte pas ce qui peut
arriver on n'est pas perdu on a quand
même le système qui fonctionne et on
peut quand même continué sa balade même
plein coeur de la forêt de rambouillet
ou 2d et 1d hollande et nicolas
justement dans un instant vous parlerez
de ces différentes randonnées possibles
et notamment à cheval on en parlera dans
quelques minutes vous parliez des vélos
je voudrais aussi m'attarder un petit
peu là dessus avec l'aiguillage ouvert
ses portes avec des nouvelles boucles
vélo aussi et des locations de vélos
possible tout à fait
c'est une maison d'éco mobilité qui
également situé en fête au pied du rer b
de saint rémy les chevreuse c'est
l'ancienne maison du garde barrière qui
a été transformée et qui aujourd'hui est
à la fois un point touristique
d'information et un site qui permet de
faire à l'année du gardiennage de vélo
de la réparation de vélos de la location
est évidemment pour le côté villégiature
des locations de vélos classiques et des
vélos électriques ce qui avec le relief
de la veille de chevreuse n'est pas
inintéressant parce que quand on n'est
pas habitué
les panoramas c'est bien mais ça veut
dire qu'il ya des côtes on monte on
descend donc quand on n'a pas l'habitude
l'assistance électrique c'est vraiment
précieux et donc voilà il ya toutes ces
batteries de vélo classique vtt voilà
qui permettent de n'emprunter celui qui
vous correspond le mieux
et puis du coup de partir sur des
circuits qui ont été repérées on vous
donne une petite cartographie vous
pouvez voilà selon le temps dont vous
disposez faire une balade courte langue
est vraiment profiter pleinement pour
découvrir les joies du vélo sans
forcément en avoir les peines quand on
n'a pas l'habitude aussi donc on vallée
de chevreuse un programme très riche et
puis pour conclure un petit peu l'été il
ya un festival qui est prévue à la fin
du mois d'août
oui à saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse c'est la
commune qui l'organisé qui a décidé
voilà de prolonger un petit peu l'été
avec sur la dernière semaine d'août en
fait un rendez-vous des visites
notamment dans la réserve naturelle de
saint rémy les chevreuse qui est une des
rares réserves naturelles en milieu
urbain puisqu'elle est au coeur des
habitations et qu'elle longe la rivière
de l'yvette donc y aura des visites
guidées il y aura des spectacles de
plein air il y aura des ateliers pour
enfants il y aura en partenariat avec la
maison raymond devos des concerts aussi
humoristique avec le barber shop quartet
qui est vraiment un super quartette
vocal voilà qui qui sera donc dans cet
équipement donc des rendez vous un peu
pour toutes catégories d'âge dans les
différents sites de la commune pour
vraiment voilà sur quatre jours avoir
l'opportunité de croiser le patrimoine
naturel qui est très riche à saint-rémy
avec tout le patrimoine historique aussi
qu' à disposition il ya là même la
maison bojan ski qui est une une maison
d'architecte voilà d'un d'un élève de
l'auteur buziet qui est situé à st rémy
qui sera également partenaire de
l'opération avec des ateliers des
spectacles ici passent donc là aussi un
beau programme
une nouveauté en plus pour cette année
donc
qui sera donc pour le mois d'août et
qu'on retrouvera sur le site du parc
voilà pour tous les renseignements
pratiques sur le site du parti pour tous
les renseignements pratiques très bien
pour la conclusion par fait d'être venu
nous parler un petit peu des différentes
activités possibles en vallée de
chevreuse nous avons adressé nous
continuons à dresser un petit peu tout
ce que vous pourrez faire si vous restez
dans ce département des yvelines et vous
n'allez pas monter d'activité et
justement pour rester dans cette vallée
de chevreuse un lieu que vous connaissez
bien évidemment un endroit que voudrait
vous faire découvrir qui n'est ni un
musée ni un espace promotionnel c'est la
fondation marta pan c'est à saint rémy
les chevreuse a permis ça permet de
découvrir le travail de sculpture
d'architecturé de marta pan mais aussi
d'andré logistique on vous avait parlé
d'un instant elle ce n'est pas ouvert en
août 1 mais s'est ouvert en juillet
voilà une petite visite guidée si vous
vouliez vous y rendre
voici la maison pensée et réalisée à
demain en 1952 à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse pas rendre
évoquant ce qui est marta pan ce célèbre
architecte et sept artistes
entretiennent l'unique maison de leur
vie qui va devenir historique la maison
elle est restée dans son état d'origine
donc on découvre ici une maison qui est
très représentative de l'esthétique des
années 50 avec des volumes très ouvert
une maison qui est très très lumineuse
une maison qui mêle espace de travail
espace de vie domestique sans aucune
séparation donc avec une porosité totale
entre les entre les deux une maison qui
a déjà tous les éléments du confort
moderne et dans le jardin vous trouvez
18 sculptures monumentales de martha
banques les installer à partir de la fin
des années 90 jusqu'à sa mort donc à
jusqu'en 2008
créateur phare de la sculpture et de l'
architecture le couple constitue une
fondation qui porte leur nom et qui au
fil des années entretient la maison nous
avons aussi un millier de dessins nous
avons l'ensemble de ces de ses écrits
sur lesquels
nous travaillons donc il ya un travail
d'inventaire et un travail classique de
conservation qui ce qui se fait au sens
muséographique du terme
et puis il ya tout un travail qui est
fait sur la connaissance la notoriété
c'est le ces deux artistes jardin
typique espaces ouverts et couleurs
sombres la maison dévoile des années
d'architecturé de création plus grande
les unes que les autres
nous accueillons ici dans des publics
professionnels d'architecte ou david
amateurs de damas plastique
nous accueillons des étudiants des
écoles d'architecturé mais nous sommes
naturellement et surtout à l'occasion
des journées du patrimoine a disposé
disponible pour recevoir un très large
public en général nous accueillons
pendant ces 48 heures environ 1000
visiteurs certains venus très loin
certains venus en voisins voilà ouverte
pour un petit nombre de public
la maison vous accueillera toute l'année
pour vous faire découvrir un espace
intime et bien pensé et nous parlions
tout à l'heure de randonnée justement
nicolas vous en avez fait quelques-unes
dans le département effectivement alors
uniquement équestre accompagné par marie
dania piceno mais on va commencer
d'abord par les randonnées pédestres
1300 km de parcours répertoriés dans les
yvelines répertoriés par kylie comité
départemental afin de rendre le parc on
s'échange les jaloux du départ tu que je
crois qu'il ya des filles pendant votre
chronique en fait c'est quoi l'amour
change de place
il ya des données pour aurélie si vous
nous rejoignez tout va bien voilà vous y
voilà qu'avec marine est donc en exemple
direction le père en yvelines c'est
juste au nord de rambouillet avec une
promenade autour des étangs de hollande
vous le voyez à l'image 7 km de
randonnée pour une durée d'environ 2
heures 30 pour un niveau un peu plus
confirmé vous pouvez avoir la balade au
bord de seine sur les boucles de
bennecourt nous sommes au nord du
département
enfin le plus long parcours du
département le randonneur et les sept
villages alors wilfried est ce que vous
serez ce randonneur et 17 villages de la
rendre et leurs essais neige c'est un
itinéraire de 30 km facile pour une
durée d'activité
ter au départ de crespières facile et
puis vous avez aussi des randonnées
ludique en famille avec une fiche de
route et des énigmes à résoudre
vous le voyez l'image un regarder ce
carnet de route pour la forêt de sainte
apolline à plaisir vous devez résoudre
une énigme à partir de dix indices des
indices qui sont associés à des lieues
de la forêt je vous propose de faire du
vélo maintenant wilfried les iphone en
matière de vélo si vous voulez que
j'aille faire un tour de vélo pendant
l'émission en fait là aussi vous avez de
nombreux itinéraires entre 10 et plus de
50 km de vélo ou de vtt sur les routes à
travers le département plusieurs
exemples de randonnée un circuit de vtt
en forêt de rambouillet 19 km 600 sur
saint quentin en yvelines vous avez
aussi des sentiers de la forêt de port
royal un parcours de 18 km au départ de
montigny le bretonneux avec un passage
par saint lambert la route du
mesnil-saint-denis un retour par la
verrière et rap
enfin dernier parcours de 72 km la
traversée du nord des yvelines au départ
de saint-germain-en laye avec un
cheminement par sartrouville maisons
laffitte
on redescend sur versailles et on
remonte par les boucles de seine au
niveau de croissy sur seine
à pied à vélo et à cheval à cheval
effectivement on compte près d'une
vingtaine de structures équestres dans
le département et direction le plus
petit village d'île de france
vous avez une idée 32 habitants le
tartre en effectuant 30 d'habitants mais
200 chevaux y compris il ya plus de
l'écheveau cadavres d'habitants
le centre équestre cheval nature propose
des randonnées notamment dans la forêt
de rambouillet regardez ce reportage sur
les images de marylène iapichino que ce
soit à travers champs ou à la lisière de
la forêt de rambouillet vous serez à
plus de deux mètres du sol pour votre
balade des promenades à cheval d'une
heure de trois heures ou d'une journée
proposée ici au centre équestre cheval
nature de la commune du tartre godrans
voilà on amène les gens là comme ça il
monte avec l'aide des plots puisque ça
nous on aime bien par rapport aux
chevaux c'est pour ménager leur dos en
fait un très vite de monter tout le
temps du sol protéger
le dos puis après ils partent ils
partent en on part on part dans les bois
là haut et gens qui savent bien monter
quand un bon niveau
ils peuvent partir seul son de
l'accompagnateur on leur donne une carte
épices des bretons les débutants les
accompagne beaucoup plus s'en aller on
va aider à préparer les chevaux les
équipes ont leur passent les casques
quand les équipes bien et on leur
explique les bases on l'aimé à cheval et
puis on va faire un petit tour beaucoup
plus tranquille parce que les débutants
ça va être beaucoup du pae du moment un
tout petit peu de trop a été
essentiellement ce qu'on peut faire
c'est leur proposez là dans les bacs
marron abois ce centre équestre existe
depuis près de 30 ans avec une vingtaine
de chevaux de différentes races pour les
balades
nous on travaille beaucoup avec des
trotteurs de
deux courses qu'on achète assez jeune
pour pour qu'ils aient pas fait de
course à proprement parler et puis
et puis on leur travail tranquillement
pendant un an ou deux pour le boulot
c'est vachement important
les fouilles bosse bien le week-end par
exemple important que le soir et suisse
soit libre et puis qu'ils puissent
marché va faire ce qu'ils ont envie
c'est de liberté
on s'est baladé un petit peu dans la
forêt on a profité un petit peu de la
fraîcheur des sous-bois et voilà on a
été surtout au pas les chevaux avaient
surtout assez chaud et puis un petit peu
trop un peu de galop mais vraiment
profiter en tant qu on a mis entre amis
ça me fait du bien d'être dans la nature
d'être au contact des chevaux de
respirer j'adore ça j'adore les chevaux
l'été 2010 9 une année particulière pour
ce centre équestre les participants de
la 52e édition de l'est qui rendent au
pourront venir à cheval nature on se
proposait en tant que quelques étapes
pour les cavaliers qui seraient de
passage pour les qui rendent au on a dit
qu'on ferait un ce que ça va être le
mercredi soir on va faire un gros
barbecue
l'equirando c'est le rendez-vous
d'équitation de l'été du 2 au 4 août le
haras des bréviaires sera le centre du
tourisme équestre européen
trois jours de fête d'activité de
randonnée dans le sud yvelines pour près
de mille cavaliers participants c'est se
promener à cheval ou en attelage pour
découvrir non seulement la région ile de
france bien sûr
et puis ensuite principalement le
département des yvelines
c'est le retour de l'est qui rendent au
en ile de france la dernière édition
francilienne a eu lieu à provins en 1993
et si vous souhaitez plus d'informations
sur les randonnées dans les yvelines que
ce soit à pied à vélo ou à cheval rendez
vous sur le site sortir tir yvelines
point fr rubrique randonnée merci
nicolas nous poursuivons ce 7,8 loisirs
spéciale était en compagnie à présent à
d'un mail aubry et bonjour bonjour si
nous avons rejoint ici donc à lille le
loisir à saint quentin en yvelines
on va parler de la programmation de
saint-quentin dont vous êtes à la
vice-présidente et dans l'agglomération
notamment ce sont les médiathèques qui
vont semer leur grain de folie une
opération est menée jusqu'au 20 juillet
oui c'est une opération qui dure du 10
au 20 juillet avec un temps fort le 19
et le 20 juillet à la commanderie des
templiers
donc c'est une
opération qui est national c'est à dire
quoi on essaye de faire sortir les
libres des médiathèques justement est
donc à l'extérieur et de présenter les
plus les libres sous toutes les formes
mais ça veut dire que jusqu'à présent
les enfin les médiathèques souffre un
petit peu quelques fois pendant l'été il
faut mieux à les sortir la culture
justement au nombre je pense que nouveau
en face il fait chaud en plus elles sont
quelquefois climati vais donc c'est pas
tes bad est agréable non c'est
simplement de montrer que le libre
comment justement ne le trouve pas que
dans les médias tels que c'est quelque
chose qui peut être intéressant d'un
point de vue loisirs il tant est qu'on
peut justement dans un cadre comme celui
ci par exemple lire cette agréable et
c'est ça l'esprit de de grain de folie
ça c'est plein de folie et donc les
médiathèques qui vont s'ouvrir il y aura
notamment les terrasses une opération
qui a déjà été mariée à la médecine
une opération qui a lieu tous les ans
c'est à dire que les médiathèques
il n'y a pas de fermeture ou de
médiathèque on a 12 médiathèque à partir
de ce moment les horaires sont
organisées et les ouvertures sont
organisés de telle façon qui est
toujours une médiathèque à proximité de
chez vous qui soit ouverte pendant tout
l'été et il ya deux médiathèque la
médiathèque du canal et les médiathèques
de plaisir qui sortent les livres à
l'extérieur qui font des terrasses ou
des plages ça donc c'est vrai sur les
deux médiathèques de plaisir et sur la
médiathèque co2 du canal à montigny les
livres les ans les autres vous les lisez
beaucoup pendant l'été sont en général
l'été que je rattrape mon retard ça que
j'achète toute l'année il ya une
enfilade de livres chez moi et l'été
j'en profite
sur la plage parce qu'en général je vais
à la plage l'été ou dans le train ou
mais vraiment le livre c'est le
rattrapage en plein été vous restez à
saint quentin en yvelines vous pouvez
donc aller les lire ses livres sur les
dans les médiathèques et puis à
l'extérieur sur leurs terres à ses pieds
un nouveau lieu culturel à saint quentin
en yvelines a qui se développe c'est la
commanderie aussi ça c'est du côté des
longs cours cette fois ci il ya pas mal
d'opérations sur la commande à la
commanderie mais y aura le temps forts
effectivement deux
de grain de folie le dit le 19 et le 20
juillet à partir de ce moment là
justement c'est tout ce qui tourne
autour du mot du livre mais on le
retrouvera aussi sous forme de contes
sous forme de jeux sous forme de théâtre
parce qu'après tout l'été le théâtre
aussi c'est de l'expression et donc on
retrouvera tout ça à la commanderie le
19 et 20 juillet pour la commanderie
projections de films également
alors après ça c'est surtout l'été tous
les jeudis soirs à 22h du cinéma en
plein air avec eux des grands classiques
va être redécouvrir les classiques et là
pendant toutes les vacances juillet et
août on appuie le programme complet sur
le site internet comme à chaque fois de
l'agglomération de 200 cadre de
l'opération sur le site des médiathèques
l'immédiat tête et sur le site de la
commanderie un petit mot de sport dans
un instant juste pour préciser s'il
était très chaud aussi que les piscines
sont ouvertes et notamment à la piscine
intercommunale celle de qui est située
sur les clayes-sous-bois pardon la
piscine salvador allende qui sera ouvert
pendant à l'été voilà pour la petite
machine communal et les piscines
communales aussi mais celle du ressort
de l'agglomération aussi alors ce mot de
sport tout simplement parce qu il y aura
qu il y aura les championnats de france
de cyclisme sur piste au vélodrome
du 10 au 17 août ces huit jours de
compétition où il y aura de nombreux
cyclistes de nombreux cris et qui sait
les portes ouvertes ni de miel peut-être
en profiter un mot de ce sport on à
monsieur sport avec nous qui d'habitude
que vous pouvez suivre sur le 7-8 sport
tous ont glané et puis le sillon par les
sports ces rendez vous cycliste
d'envergure est effectivement oui ben il
y aura tout simplement des cyclistes de
haut niveau à le dire mais le bruit le
disait vrai juste avant il y aura
notamment françois pervis qui a gagné
six titres de champion du monde donc ce
n'est pas rien il faut les lois il ya
également quelques pépites comme
mathilde de gros par exemple qui sera
présente sur la piste du vélodrome et
ils attendent environ entre cinq et huit
mille personnes sur l'ensemble de la
compétition sur l'agglomération la
fédération sur l'agglomération de beaux
rendez vous donc à suivre
merci beaucoup mais l'ouvrier d'être
passé pour cette édition du 7 8 loisirs
et puis michael puisque vous avez eu
micro vous le gardez vous êtes allé
vous essayez au golf exactement j'ai
tapé la petite balle blanche et ce n'est
pas s'en plaindre wilfried mais j'ai
essayé à regarder nous sommes au golf
blue green de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
et nous allons tenter à 2 testé à le
golf aujourd'hui pour m'aider dans cette
tâche je suis à côté de williams où il
ya le programme aujourd'hui
alors nous aujourd'hui en fait on va
d'abord commencer par faire du poitiers
pour faire un petit peu nos premiers
lancers ensuite on attend son appel du
petit jeu donc c'est des coups qui sont
autour du drapeau et ensuite en fait on
va mettre des ensembles à faire un
parcours pour voir un grand bain un
petit peu ce que ça donne c'est pas trop
difficile non ça va après faut juste
insisté un petit peu persévérer mais
sinon c'est quand même un spa en lecteur
c'est super agréable donc c'est parti on
va prendre les matches aller
[Musique]
alema tel-aviv a
donc là je tire de tout l'effort souvent
doucement pour commencer progressivement
on va augmenter ok ok la première
difficulté rencontrée
première difficulté taper la balle tout
simplement toucher la balle du coup je
prend de l'élan et après je fais avec
l'ensemble donc il va falloir en fait la
faire la même chose c'est-à-dire un jeu
prend de l'élan et 2 je vais utiliser
ensemble pour propulser la balle
[Musique]
lavallois s'est mieux passé graff et je
pense que c'est bon pour le practice on
va faire quoi maintenant on va aller
faire du coup duty je sais bien qu'on va
récupérer quelques balles puis en avant
avec le soleil qui arrive en plus
est-ce que tu as quelques conseils à me
donner oui alors du coup on va mettre
non plus quelques-uns on va se mettre
juste en face aux quais
en fait le petit c'est juste deux choses
à gérer vitesse et direction pour la
vitesse en fait ce qui est très
important c'est de faire un petit coup à
vide pour essayer de ressentir un petit
peu mouvement de balancier parce que la
vitesse du potter a donné en fait la
vitesse de la balle
donc c'est très important de préparer un
petit peu son dosage en regardant
régulièrement trou avant de jouer et
ensuite de bien prendre le temps
d'allier la baballe lepeu terre et
ensuite d'exécuter ce qu'on a décidé
comme dosage je vais essayer de faire
aussi bien on va voir
[Musique]
et tu vas donc du coup de maître à
courir regarder un petit peu comme un
ivrogne toujours rêvé de faire ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
donc c'est terminé ouais on va aller sur
le parcours mettre en place tout ça pour
voir les deux ensemble ce que ça va
donner exactement mais le but du jeu
c'est gamme ds sur le parcours donc
c'est parti on y va on se jette dans le
grand bain allez là du coup on est sur
un par-3 donc le passé l'objectif d'un
joueur professionnel pour un débutant c6
donc on va voir si après ces petits
conseils tu arrives du coup à faire
l'objectif
on va essayer à l'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hier ça
merci merci beaucoup en tout cas pour
cette session si on veut tester le golf
ici à saint quentin en yvelines comment
ça se passe alors si on veut tester en
fait on fait des initiations payante
jusqu'au 13 septembre
et à partir de cette date là en fait
jusqu'à fin octobre nous ont des
initiations gratuites donc on verra tout
le monde donc
venez nombreux et comme quoi c'est pour
tous les niveaux moi j'ai réussi à le
faire donc pourquoi pas vous merci
beaucoup williams avec plaisir et moi je
vais continuer un petit peu le golfe
alors après avoir vu les exploits inde
et mickaël vidéo on vous a vu taper la
balle blanche
moi je vais vous quittez un héros au
caire je vais vous quittez tout de suite
je vous souhaite déjà d'excellentes
vacances et puis un bon été et moi je
vais vous quittez pour réaliser mon défi
ben je viens de trouver une carte
transmettez cette carte à quelqu'un sans
qu'il vous remarque il me semble c'est
la carte de manon varaldo donc manon a
réussi son défi est maintenant c'est à
mon tour de réaliser mon défi donc je
vais ouvrir les enveloppes que m'a
transmis marylène tout à leur demander
un autographe sur cette carte à un
inconnu comme s'il était une star c'est
parti
[Musique]
je crois percevoir quelqu'un qui fait de
la voile là bas avec est super connue
excusez moi bonjour je crois vous
reconnaitre maintenant on peut avoir un
autographe coup de mou voilà merci
beaucoup
donc vous êtes célèbre navigatrice
voilà c'est ça donc voila voila marylène
défi relevé justement marienne on en est
où des défis largement il manquait
nicolas je crois qu'il ya mais la nuit
est encore en cours manon mais je pense
qu'elle a été plus discrète donc on
séparait encore ce sera une surprise
après si elle a relevé ou non son défi
moi j'ai relevé le mien oui on l'a
ensuite vu c'est bon ça s'était très
discret de manière tout à fait naturelle
et il restera celui de nicolas on verra
s'ils y arrivent avant la fin de cette
émission les émissions qui se termine
tout de même on va remercier l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines qui
nous a accueillis qui nous a permis
d'installer un autre plateau ici on va
vous souhaiter un très bel été et puis
on se retrouve tous et toutes à la
rentrée à partir du mois de septembre à
2 septembre pour la reprise du journal
d'ici là un très bel été à tous et à
toutes
[Musique]
oh